bring up one into hello everybody
we had to call an audible as I mentioned
in our tweet because apparently there
was a new patch that got pushed for
overwatch it was a mysterious patch we
were like what is this what is this
patch about there's a it was really
pretty substantial and it looks like
it's introduced some new arcade modes
all new for the public it's been yep
then on PTR for a bit mm-hmm I'm Justin
and this is Eric and I think we're gonna
try it so when we hop in there Justin
you got the controls today as I'm gonna
attempt to play and do all right so
click game and pip you see that little
thing right next to the yep click that
guy boom I'm gonna do one more thing for
you I'm gonna pull up chat for us
alright we're gonna go try to we're
gonna do the FFA first oh crap I'm on
Joey's account I meant to go on my
account but hey you know that's alright
a little bit so we get game audio like
go halfway oh dude he's got sick Reaper
Reaper
not as a nice Reaper so if you have any
questions or comments or you just want
to tell us how awesome Eric is at the
game you can join us on twitch chat and
on YouTube and on gamespot comm where
we're live-streaming it right now and
we'll be looking at your comments
answering questions walks and responding
to your very very nice comments about us
about my horrible reaper gameplay old
man tay on the sticks today I miss Joey
already Joey where are you why are you
on vacation
somebody plushie games says why No
Limits is not here no there's a mariachi
Reaper trying to hunt me down here so
you guys have spent a little bit of time
in this already correct and I don't know
if there's really gonna be any changes
for the know it being live in the game
no it's just if you weren't able to play
it and for console players they're gonna
be able to you know check it out
no no no that's
ah macri's a bunch of McCree so what did
you think of it I mean team deathmatch
is something that overwatch is not
balanced or it is not
yeah I mean that's why it's only in
arcade mode you know so but it's still
fun like ID'd you in that do you enjoy
playing this very more traditional
watches heroes considering I just played
a bunch of duty
I mean in terms of at least TDM I was
playing a lot at TDM offensively as a
server playing on PC yes we are this
should be live now on ps4 and Xbox one
as well yes confirmed this is actually
live on live servers not PTR so I would
assume at some point it should hit
constants - right I would assume yeah
you might be slightly there we don't
know these is usually a little bit
slower than PC but usually it's on point
but if you go to log in on your
overwatch account on PC right now you
should be getting a patch and several
gigs once you download no no no no it
looks like you might be able to jump
into some team deathmatch matches with
us
ah no no no sir no sir your wheel is not
coming out you almost got me there
though that was pretty dangerous
I need more health but yeah it's about
this is the new map to chateau if people
haven't seen it yet this is not good
interviewed or trying to play it
yourself you didn't see it in there you
have arcade mode open maybe while you're
at work when you're supposed to be doing
other things you just need to close the
game it's all you yeah it's about six
gigs so just know it's a pretty hefty on
so team deathmatch obviously it's it's
focused on it's not a little gameplay so
do you feel like there's a heavier focus
on DPS yeah I mean obviously I don't
think you're gonna play mercy in this
mode that would be silly
yeah but I'm jumpy tiara doesn't that's
not the same you think that she's the
changes they've made were on PTR or
enough to make her a viable choice in
this I still don't think so but I mean
some people can prove me wrong I mean
she's gonna get balanced right if she's
not balanced right now that's what PTR
is for it's to balance the game yes so
the strangest diva and mercy as the
[ __ ] might have gone through some big
changes but that right now that's just
on PTR that's not something that's
introduced into the full game yet some
kind Danu Beachbody McCree you're gonna
give us a bad name
hey I'm second all right we're playing
on Julie's account so that's how
accidental is there I'm on his PC Oh God
any other new changes in the mattress
right now it looks like it's just these
modes add it to arcade I will be looking
for the the official full update patch
notes from Blizzard to see what all this
includes if there's anything else goin
fara pair is pretty good on this map I'm
probably died here
yeah fare was pretty good on this map
for verticality it's kind of annoying to
deal with there there was it's funny
because I haven't seen a dufus and there
are so many doom fists when me and Joey
were playing PTR but yeah well I feel
like PTR you're gonna do more
experimental stuff than you don't know
people were like oh dude pissed ope
I feel like this guy's exploring and I'm
actually playing the game you know it's
it's out in the wild right now God
getting more information soon
just looking on the game pages to see if
there's anything out there well you want
so what is your go-to dps character is
it it's probably Reaper to be honest
this is not a good place to be is high
ground it's first a 20 I believe - oh
crap so in especially with so many
shooters coming out this fall do you
feel like that's changing the way that
you play over sorry we've spent a lot of
time in the office playing Call of Duty
stupid last hit no I mean this is live
golden King just so you know it's it's
actually live proper it hasn't really
eat it's not really gonna change I mean
like there's more differences here and
overwatch because it's a hero based
shooter
I can't pause that actually just in case
thanks umm and so I feel like because
there's so many so many different styles
of Heroes here and how they play it's
different from like your Call of Duty
obviously right which is more of a
traditional you have certain types of
guns and they do have loadouts but you
know there's not gonna be someone
blinking around like a tracer so alright
we can try going May here
she seems I think she would be pretty
decent just because she can heal herself
she has annoying things to do are the
new mercy abilities I'm the update I
don't know Sombra not positive on that
did you pull up the patch notes so much
so it looks like haven't been posted yet
this might have gone live just a little
bit early in the game so we're getting a
maybe an early preview you should call
it mercy play some mercy I believe I
don't I don't even believe in myself
right now that it's to know if all this
is Joey's account so
I guess that's kind of true but still
and the Summer Games have ended max are
you gone buddy
where you going Gabor's do you know if
that's right I think summer either ended
or ended this week and so this is taking
that someone's trying to mercy right now
looks like it's not working yep mercy
not quite as effective or maybe just
that player if tape in-flight mercy
probably would death matches it is I
think an interesting yeah we so we're
playing the free-for-all just so
everyone knows this is first 220 we can
switch to team deathmatch here in a
second that looks like barbecue salon
killing I think it's just one of those
fun modes to have like just to kind of
cleanse the palate every now and then
you don't have to play objective place
base gaming you can just kind of like
enjoy so when you have free time I we
have to play it a lot of these games we
have to obviously your downtime how are
you spending your I honestly haven't
been playing as much like stuff as I
used to mainly because life I've played
a lot of breath of the wild right now I
probably mostly you know I still dabble
in hearthstone every now and then
because it's just a nice little casual
game that you can hop into destiny
obviously destiny two's coming out next
week so I've been playing that I played
a lot of the cod multiplayer beta this
weekend not only for work but it just
kind of felt good again to play that
kind of cod not so futuristic which was
refreshing
a few people popping into
into our stream right now this patch is
live right now in the game and it looks
like other people are recording that
they're seeing it on the ps4 there's a
massive update which you can download
for your game and it seems like the
person or what it seems to unlock right
now is is team deathmatch in the arcade
mode and free-for-all yep right now
we're playing around in some
free-for-all where I think some
characters are still gonna be more
differently balanced than others I'm
trying to get to try out some may did
not work I mean I'm not me
mercy are you trying to get me to play
mercy yeah I'm trying to get you to play
mercy you've seen other people fail at
mercy that is it maybe they're just not
good at mercy get out of here and so we
don't know everything that the patch
includes quite yet we're waiting for the
official word from blue posts exactly
what this is the only thing I find
annoying about this mode the way it
works and for free-for-all specifically
is just that is that it's last hit it's
not how much damage you do so it's kind
of frustrating because someone could
just like get like you know finishing
touch on someone and that counts as a
kill so TDM is a little bit more
interesting because you actually can
play it like overwatch where you know
you have heels if I could hit somebody
god good shoe says that that the mercy
change did not but I still think you
should try mercy and they also say to
refresh
so if you guys are seeing the update
from Blizzard if you could let us know
where they posted oh come on and I
didn't get that oh no I didn't get it
because the other person got it it's
stupid that it tells you like you did X
and I damaged because someone else if
that McCree touched her at all after I
did all that damage all right so we have
the patch notes for the patch highlights
which as we see from going into Arcade
Mode includes Team Deathmatch and
free-for-all death match as we've seen
from the PTR previously 8 players go
head-to-head until one player scores 20
points players are at one point whenever
they land a final blow on an opponent
and lose one point whenever they die to
environmental damage like falling off a
cliff as we've seen a couple times whoa
I have you getting punted off there's a
difference sure sure
I haven't jumped off myself this is not
being team deathmatch
two teams of four players face off both
modes will play out on a selection of
maps so hunter burrow horizon team
deathmatch is only in Black Forest
Castillo echo point in metropolis and so
it looks like there's also those maps
will have slight changes according to
the patch notes some of the maps will
restrict blades and specific areas and
develop a scuffle V spawn system when
playing is specifically in team
deathmatch deathmatch modes and there's
a brand new map specifically for
deathmatch chateau gr which we're
playing on right now which we also
talked about a bit of PTR but now
everybody gets to try it out and play so
silly I've done so much damage as so
many of these guys
tonight what that far it feels like to
that so this has a pretty substantial
updates that go along with it I think
most people are reporting over six gigs
there's a developer comment in the patch
notes it says over the past few months
we've been working on a number of
significant under-the-hood changes will
help us streamline the patching process
this will allow us to reduce the
download size in future patches but does
mean to the today's patch is larger than
a traditional patch so I don't actually
know what that means but I guess they
will be smaller going forward and this
one is just really big because because
as two modes there's an ease in option
that's added under the Advanced tab in
the controller menu to allow players to
customize their turn rate acceleration
that's pretty cool and if that Morford
console or I could have stopped it no
and my old minor reactions it looks like
there's some minor changes just some of
the characters Orissa wrote Hagen why
don't we go specifically with it looks
likes ye slight changes to tuning Road
hogs take a breather can now be used
well moving yeah that was in PTR
and we don't makers pull down on a
grappling hook in a mine and some bug
fixes so say yeah other people are
recording a 16 gigabyte download really
yeah oops you asked how do we unlock the
young tastes skin that's a good question
I don't know I don't know how to
activate that anymore there's only one
taste skin young day and old tale at the
same time
now III imagine myself to be a lot more
like shorter yeah old Tay
and like look like a slight hunched and
maybe a cane all right we're gonna try
TDM which should be at least obviously
more team-based and not so solo that was
a free-for-all we can go back to
free-for-all in a little bit but at
least here you know you do have you do
want to have like a healer
you know you probably maybe one tank and
then to like damage dealers um so what
role do you usually like to fill in
these mmm I end up usually having a play
support tank cuz I even though I don't
want to just because that's generally
just how it goes
I feel like which is why most people or
most advice would be that you want to
have one of each kind of like character
type so you could play anything and just
get good with one of each
I'm Jed oh hell lobby this is live on
the server's apparently it's been on ps4
- according to the chat so thank you
guys in chat for telling us that if
you're not seeing it refresh yeah Solow
this is live this is not PTR TDM Team
Deathmatch and free-for-all are both now
an actual live overwatch so you'll head
over to the arcade and you have a trial
and so this is where I haven't played on
this Bob Jones 1980 I think ass
interesting question over on Twitter and
it's do you think will continue support
I don't see continuing support on
overwatch or whether they might make a
sequel next year I don't think you don't
think it'll be a think it's just gonna
be over watch how come because they
still haven't like filled out the roster
totally you know and they're just
continue to you know add more heroes
when they can and also you know that
seems to be what they're going for as
well that this is less a game that we'll
see see closely the story is something
that it really takes place outside of
the game more than anything else so it's
not something where you need the game
itself so or you don't need a new game
to tell a different story they're adding
new maps they're adding new characters
and the story is taking place and
shortening comics and all these places
outside of the game itself and also I
feel like they really want to push this
as a potential eSport and I think
Blizzard obviously with their yeah they
have the overwatch like world league
which is cool because it's how it should
be right like it should be
representative of a country and not what
like you know League of Legends
necessarily has become which is like you
have Koreans and Europeans on US teams
and they're not true - it's more like
Olympic sports at that point right which
i think is cool i think things you can't
keep updating you can't keep changing
the game we want it to be a viable
and I think that's one of the things
that might perk call of duty a bit in
trying to have a consistent peace work
you see something like League of Legends
or dota where the hell did they continue
to change it or something like overwatch
where you have minor tweaks over a long
period of time when the entire game
changes that I think that's harder for
people to track both at from a spectator
standpoint as well as for gamers like
that's asking you to invest something it
is something entirely different
crap talk about a terrible place to be
right now we're playing on PC hey
soldier 76 real basic I'm a real basic
guy it's in it's in right you said yeah
so three characters have their updates
that we saw earlier on PTR which are now
live in this version of the game as well
and that's Theresa Roadhog and
Widowmaker the road hog one I think in
particular and damage taken while
healing has been reduced by 50% it's
this a pretty good pump that we have we
don't have a tank but I used to old okay
I have alt but I haven't seen a good
amount of people so also there they're
Reinhart thin like walking a lot you're
fine
that way you wanted you wanted a little
oh come on we almost got the triple so I
know when the these updates started
coming out of it fellas well playing
obviously some really gets in you were I
think in particular excited about giving
a lot of the the skins unlocking a lot
of these these characters different
digital thousand you've had to give that
up to Joey who we've done a lot about
watch streams with recently yeah do you
has that kind of killed your desire to
know to collect them all or useful no no
I mean I collect the ones I want like I
got the Genji are like raiding skin
they're like almost like revengeance
looking skin
come on guys so I mean when there's
skins I want or when there's events I'll
always play for a couple days you know
get your free loop box and all that okay
I'm sure we'll have some more skins
coming up soon ah September coming up
very soon which means October is just
around the corner they're not looking to
have the exact same things happen ever
given fit when they were talking about
this in their views they I don't want
things to be a surprise you don't know
exactly what's gonna happen at any time
but I think we can still expect
something to happen around Halloween
mm-hmm
yeah curious if it's like the junker
town thing I hope it is like like more
of a play on that that would be kind of
cool
yeah junker town which was announced at
Gamescom I'm sure that'll be something
that we get to play more soon I think as
we've seen previous years like I
convolve was announced at Gamescom your
previous month later that came out on
PTR we were able to try that out but I
feel like there's gonna be something for
Halloween in particular like that's junk
junker Town is not necessarily the
replacement for Halloween Yolo good job
I didn't do much there see so that was
kind of cool so more Maps obviously for
TDM yeah sorry fallout shelter it's been
a while since I've had to play and talk
at the same time it's not apparently
that easy I've usually been sitting over
there which is like real easy because I
just look at chat for you guys and then
like just watch people play which is
which is pretty easy but I will try to
get back into it let's see let's May was
doing a good job I feel like also
because I'm
on me may all day yeah and uh asking is
this available on normal overwatch yes
right now
this is a patch which is open in the
regular game it sounds like it's live on
we're playing on PC it sounds like it's
live on ps4 according to guys in the
chat if you're playing on xbox and you
want to try that out if you have the
game at home and you want to see if it's
live let us know it drop out comment if
this is something you can play on Xbox
as well but no matter what it sounds
like it's gonna come out today for
everybody so it should be live very soon
thank you Alex and Norma saying you're
doing awesome I would like to think
that's both of us though Justin so
you're also doing awesome good job I am
no replacement for our normal overwatch
do we have a healer I'm the person they
bring in when we're just out of other
people that's not true yeah I read well
gamers I'd love to have junker town
don't know when that's ever gonna drop
but hopefully soon because Gamescom did
just happen so yeah we got some new
stuff mm-hmm
yeah as Hisham abou as mentioned yeah
it's gonna be a little bit unbalanced
for I mean it's only in arcade mode so
they don't really need to balance you
know as much here I will try to heal
Nutcracker let's go that's it that's an
interesting choice nice pika power
saying my xbox overwatch is updating
awesome so it's another confirmation
also just as a pro tip guys if you guys
are having problem downloading the patch
if you're like already in the game or
like on your console sometimes you need
to like kind of like back out of the
game or like restart your console and
that's like a good way to kind of
kickstart that update so definitely try
that and where they at where they at
this is awkward so also high
littlefoot's what a koala sweetie sorry
if I do that sorry I cut you off
oh god yeah and as people are mentioning
the diva and mercy updates that we've
been talking about on PTR those aren't
live in the game quite yet no not
currently
I'm coming Zarya
so overwatch is not gonna be something
that's in our intention for a game of
the year even though this is something
that I feel like a lot of us in the
office do spell school still spend quite
a bit of time with but there are a lot
of shooters out there this year that I
think Tang in particularly gonna be
spending some time with yeah definitely
curious about destiny obviously oh come
on guys
yes we're doing work I was on fire
Azaria so someone says what does ff8
that is free-for-all
that's the I basically just deathmatch
right now we're trying out the team
deathmatch mode there any new skins no
not that I know of right now it looks
like the update is primarily to
introduce these new modes into arcade
mode which we saw earlier on PTR as in
the ahta is definitely my go-to because
he can still kind of DPS which is what I
like about I like hybrid characters that
can kind of do both and if you go over
to PTR you can try out those mercy I use
my all to save myself because I didn't
want to die for that may selfish place
this one it's about wonder if you can
spawn camp because it kind of feels like
there's some of the Hat that's like some
ecology stuff if anything oh yeah yeah
playing the Call of Duty beta definitely
reminded me of that style
oh please air oh nice
yes so the Summer Games event is over
all in a shock it's been replaced in the
arcade by this new free-for-all mode and
team deathmatch
and we've had some updates to some of
the characters that we we've mentioned a
couple times but if there are always new
people coming into the chat road hog or
rice yeah we can do some road hog in a
second I did I do play a little bit of
road hog probably miss a bunch of hooks
has been reduced from 12 seconds to
eight and her venom line which affected
targets are now visible through walls to
you as whatever oh please don't go down
there like getting tuned to an T but
this is this has been a good people have
have asked about the size of the patch
in the patch notes
it looks like the developers did make
mention of this particular side which is
over the developers for overwatch said
then over the past few months we've been
working on a number of significant
under-the-hood changes that will help us
nice to loot boxes so far and this will
allow us to reduce the download size in
the future patches but it does mean that
today's patch is larger than a
traditional patch I think some people
were reporting like 12 gigs for us it
was around 6 gigs yeah fallout shelter
we did notice the slight youtube update
to the design at least I did it
definitely has a new like there's a good
new icon as well so yeah it is on ps4 k
kgo thanks everyone for tuning in
obviously I'm Eric that's Justin we're
playing this new mode look at that 53%
kill participation as a healer stay as a
team guys come on here yeah I'll just
vote for myself
stinky vote that's good for votes
Erica's are normal overwatch no join us
today and I am
a unworthy standard no you're not that's
not true at all you guys stop selling
yourself short Justin does have the the
patch notes up so if there's any
questions regarding that that you guys
want to see or hear about I'm not gonna
be boring and just just doing anything
yeah yeah so basically that's going on
yeah destiny beta is also available on
open beta now PC if you guys haven't
played that that's available today I
know a lot of people were asking
yesterday when we were live-streaming
that so which I wrote hog on battlenet
if you're playing on PC which is such a
weird thing to see like is it like
pulling up battlenet you have destiny
sounds like some people are freaking out
from junk update is big so kind of
commenting again on the junk right
update in the patch notes oh oh yeah no
he isn't there so junk yes got double
yeah he was really strong hold two mines
and the rip tires movement has been
increment percent speed movement and
there's no longer a time limit when wall
climbing it's weird even that audio is
different that's crazy I've never gone
out there but we're playing this Road
Dogg I'm not dead
take a breather can be used while moving
and damage taken while healing has been
reduced by 50% that's pretty big so if
dies I don't that's a good point
look here we'll do that take a breather
there it is there's the heal while
walking which is pretty massive to be
honest
getting the hooks just not getting the
kills here oh yeah this is good
so if you guys have any questions or
comments about either lesson you can go
ahead and hit us up on Twitter chat on
YouTube and on site we have three of
those get on Winston and this is part of
the new update there was a patch that
went out for the game just this morning
pretty substantial this is a bad look a
multi gig update which introduces RK of
rebrov and team deathmatch into into the
arcade right yeah we're currently the
live version doing the four before team
deathmatch or as my team I need heels
please at least kill him
no I play some road hog there's no
excuse Jesus all right where is my team
is like all over the place
oh I sorry I'm used to I usually put my
mouse scroll wheel as my melee and so
I'm pressing the wrong button
obviously asks at GameSpot are you guys
pro in overwatch no we're not so right
now I'm playing with Eric Tay who is
eSports no I'm not normally we have Joey
who's our other overwatch esports
champion
Pro eSports in Animal Crossing that's
pretty good and I have watched pro
eSports Pokemon before that's probably
bad
I really suck it all shooters I'm a
mercy name so I like to eat and stay out
of the fight darn it oh yeah yeah so the
creepy penguin asks I'm new to the
channel but what are your mains as I
mentioned I'm 100% of RC bein I like to
play blue co2 I like to be the healer in
agreement I like giving the wrong ones
you play a bit of junk bread but what
are your mains my mains are
lucio I got the console lucio soldier
Reaper may Zenyatta sometimes Reinhardt
my Reinhardt's not so great though yeah
like I said you want to try to have like
one of each dude so we don't have a
healer on our team yes be part of the
problem right now
I can always jump into a game like no
one else wants to be yeah and so I
didn't realize we didn't have a healer
that was pretty bad to be honest I had
known I would have gone heals on ps4 PC
and sounds like Xbox one the updates are
out there now as well too if this is
something you want to try it yourself it
is it's opening the live game
great a Hanzo play of the game everyone
get excited sorry
how many Hanzo mains are there in chat
be ashamed of yourself spam it alright
look at that 78% hook accuracy sure hi
Sam TV what's up welcome to the chat
jump Pat kills yeah it's pretty good
alright PP oh hell yeah ps4 update it
looks like it's almost 16 gig
no you don't have that's bad news right
there whenever you see it your tank even
though road hog is kind of like a hybrid
tank have gold over your golda limbs
it's not a that's not good look Justin I
earned them dang it I earned them I'm
gonna go healer again I think in
addition to introducing team deathmatch
and free-for-all to the to the main game
it also brought some changes to a few
characters including junk rat making him
totally Opie orissa how do you say
alright central Reesa Reesa Reesa Reesa
or it could be IRISA wow there are a lot
of Hanzo means proud Hanzo main joshua
Nell Oh God come on a ring chat there's
a spam domain in there too
so and as we talked about a bit as well
they're in PTR there are some changes
that have been made sativa and mercy the
mercy wants ending is particularly
interesting but those are not in this
available on PTR Oh Lord why am I here
witch
oh hi eat AJ hey and goo Bay hyah yeah
all right we gotta we gotta switch it up
so we got a main adhere to the EOP
person I hear Genji all which is not
good come on give me something to wear
that was in jacket does Roadhog we're
getting smashed right oh we're actually
it's not as bad as I thought we are
getting smashed though yeah no no no run
from me choke her head please Genji
please that'll be interesting to see how
the mercy changes when they go alive
inside a game really affect things I I
don't think it's okey but I feel like it
really will change the way their system
and lucy has a good deal yeah let's see
it was fun song she's got a revival off
Gucci has a protest leave your healers
behind don't protect ya what's that
he is straight-up tunneling me thank you
I am here when you jump right oh no it's
gonna be a really like I've actually
even though this is a bit of a surprise
drop in the pillow but it's just Tuesday
middle today this just comes out I'm
kind of glad that it's coming now be or
things get really crazy cuz the next
couple weeks for gaming or not gonna be
they're not gonna be tamed no no I get
to the imagination if this is fronting
this is one of the biggest balls I can
think up for a long time
and we all know eSports hey it's gonna
be much whole one at destiny - correct
what are you you're probably gonna be
meeting that on top so rather than yeah
yeah yeah correct
oh no out of here
dude are we sure Genji was as good as
that other Genji break it down save my
team really take some skill that's what
I'm really bad out of it
I'm not that great I know me there and
to be honest I I think he's awesome as
like a god I mean kill the healer in
case you're just joining us we're
playing the new overwatch update which
it looks like is live now across all the
pencils and PC in the real game and it
introduces free-for-all mode FFA as well
as team deathmatch 14 adult where Tay is
seating is the healer it's not oh come
on I'm still good right I can climb that
come on Lucy oh but if it works if you
were thinking about trying this out
yourself if you're at home or you have
access to your ps4 or Xbox one remotely
definitely recommend trying to start
this download early since it's like it's
16 games on console this is a sizable
update
but according to the overwatch patch
notes there'll probably be some changes
goes forward that will make these less
double tank size intensive and in
addition to the new modes the patches
this patch introduces some changes to
some of the characters including jump
rat or Lisa
roll call again Widowmaker truck red one
in particular that's Joe crack can now
hold two concussion mines and the RIP
tire is 30% faster and there's no limit
on wall climbing no time limit on wall
climbing dude I swear that that opposing
genji has gone is all at three times as
a keV says we need a report system ASAP
on console no I play PC only sending 23
says updates everywhere today there's a
one complaint as well
really everyone I want to spend some
more time in when like Jake and John
Luke very big on blind I know that the
stone is stole my favorite digital art
game right now but Elder Scrolls legends
is there's a really good contender on
that single player mode I their
single-player is really fun and Gwent is
something I want to spend some more time
with yeah that was tough guys man they
have vertical superiority Wow our again
G got to play the game sucking 27 says
hey souls levitate did you try all night
I am NOT why do you guys like console so
much I personally like PC I mean it
depends on the game obviously I'm gonna
leave this game and join again maybe it
opens up boxes like I'll probably play
destiny on console as well just because
more people like think on our team we're
gonna be playing on console but for the
most part also because destiny PC
doesn't come out for like I'm the one
that 1/2 or something after actual
launch and I don't want to reform that's
why we play on the American servers yes
neo Kherson there was a someone asked
would we do the junker junker town
stream if when junker town comes out
probably yeah I know something that was
announced during Gamescom which looks
like it's a new map kind of focused on
in Australia which Blizzard apologize
for not getting everything quite right
about Australia of course in a joking
those but as soon as that drops you know
I expect to see it sometime in the next
couple weeks especially since we saw it
at Gamescom where it was revealed and we
got a healer and stuff we've seen out of
games come tends to come out pretty soon
after on PTR here we can try junk rat I
mean I'm not the greatest don't grab but
you know maybe I don't think people
argue that it takes crazy amounts of
skill I guess because you can just dude
he's already in there by himself
and playing shooters on like I'm really
it is I'm not a great shooter player to
begin twisting playing on mon-sol makes
me feel even more handicapped like at
least on PC I could move around quickly
I can aim really quickly and accurately
on console I just feel so hamstrung yeah
good see that and it really reminded me
how bad I am try to PC I say it's like
going back into the Destiny the destiny
to beta which is now open to the public
on PC that reminded me how much easier
it is to get that shots on PC at least
for me or on controller I think here in
the office we have a guy named Nikola
Parker Vita who is a cloud console
player he plays overwatch on on
controller and he's surprisingly good at
it
now you're giving Nicky marks a lot of
credit I don't think he's that good for
a controller I think it's actually if
you played PC I feel like it's actually
easier for then of PC yeah
it depends on the character Widowmaker
is AI little makers not fun puzzle that
somebody like a white heart like I think
that translate things really well over
to the console yeah because you can try
no adversity like how is he not in the
trap dude the trap was right next to him
I laid it down there on purpose
okay got someone there why don't you
blow up
all right so we're playing team
deathmatch now and representing a London
appearance it's 11:00 to 6:00
that's it right click between console
and PC no I don't know how true this is
because it's more anecdotal but it feels
like when you're on console you get a
lot more people who just main dps we're
seeing that a lot in the comments as
well yeah that's kind of I could kind of
see that I mean like you got to think
about the console audience right they're
used to playing DPS type shooters right
and that's what soldier 76 is for that's
for people who play Call of Duty and
want to be able to jump into overwatch
know what they're doing you have a whole
character and PC people are used to
playing like mmo's and those kind of
games where you have healers different
kinds of classes so I could see that
being a problem but I don't know I
always just play what we're missing
early yeah yeah yeah no no no he's right
I was not right-clicking my mines yeah
and then I figured that out just now
that's my fault thank you
how can't you
TV movie
type 10 plus 18 overwatch sex I think he
might have been accidentally thinking
this was his Google search bar hey you
don't want to be reading that Justin
that's not good is that some people are
saying like Zak F that he's not gonna
lie he's really bad music mouse keyboard
well you're finally getting that that's
fam this is kind of actually crazy goop
shoot says Chuck your minds like their
mates
yeah I'm trying she uses that diva just
bullied the crap out of them players is
sitting on your couch just having a
controller and not having to say yeah
but you could play a console on thing I
feel like that's too much of a
disadvantage if you're putting against
keyboard about players like controller
put you at a disadvantage oh dang if
that mercy got away
so right now we're in the overwatch
update which has gone live on PC ps4 and
it sounds like Xbox one is substantial
enough sixteen gigabytes it introduces
the free-for-all mode and team
deathmatch right now we're a team
deathmatch which is live for everybody
and not just et Arbutus no it's PTR same
for Diablo
it's PTR if you want to try this out
trying to download it yourself although
unless you have to get those 16 gigs
they're gonna play junk right one more
time now that I blew her away other says
so in addition to these new mines pretty
crazy now though so which was chateaux
did something it's like widow-makers
house I believe died I died
right it's gotta be die die die yeah oh
what a bad time to revive for you
wait oh okay I guess you got a slow
triple ooh that mercy did work in
addition to the new match our and in
addition to the new modes and arcade
there are also some changes to the
characters we were just playing around
with junk rat who could now hold two
minds to concussion mines we didn't see
his rip tire though did we
I use my rip tire for a second Reese has
some changes road hog has some really
big changes being able to move while you
take a breather and also having damage
reduced by 50% and Widowmaker has some
smaller that's a while healing though
wow that 50% yeah not overall no yeah
that would be crazy
just want to make sure people know that
I mean I could try to go Widow it would
be a travesty though I feel like yeah
I'll try it I try for like a couple
times and then that's it what makers
changes this time around that her cool
down for the grappling hook has been
reduced from 12 second state needs and
her venom mine the affected targets are
now visible through walls but only to
the players Widowmaker the developers
were saying that her abilities felt a
little bit weak and the crapola cooldown
reduction she's more likely to have it
try one more time and then that's it I
can't I was just talking about this the
other day where like the impact that
Widowmaker can have versus like a bad
one god no leave me alone diva you never
saw me
god this is so tough to watch so we're
playing right now with eSports hey no
I'm not it'll make her main can you stop
please
so we're trying we're trying out
Widowmaker because she has she has some
changes just wanted to see I mean you
can get away faster budge this is so bad
alright alright it's just there I hit a
hole nice job alright we're done with
that I'm sorry that you guys had to
witness that
you can't I'm up that I'm a little bit
better but not that much better is it
like it's at least more oh hello
why are you still inside fair I should
be up and over everybody
an esport stay is teh is old nickname
since retired okay thanks need to warm
back up no no no it's not yeah I know I
need to eSports Joey here Joey is our
others if you tuned it for any of our
other overwatch screens you probably see
Joey these are young up-and-coming
eSports star picking spot office back in
the eSports days Tay was known to points
out as old McNish Wow
great but a guy named big fan so now
working you wait like 40 McNuggets I'm
not proud of that master 56 if we go
back to widow maker has a pro tip to try
quickscoping with widow okay that's
definitely gonna help me Pro tips I can
tell going back to soldier 76
go with what you know oh that's a trap
monkey oh shoot my Zenyatta isn't there
no no no not like this then you know
we're kind of in a slower period before
the really big rush of games is this the
kind of thing that will be people bring
or people back you know over watch as we
kind of get into the ball of shooters
it's gonna be a really heavy shooter
season coming up uh I mean I think
people that are playing overwatch you're
gonna play overwatch and if there's a
game that might pull some people away it
might be destiny to but that's kind of
in the same family even though blizzard
and Bungie or yeah but different kind of
game right like this is a more
competitive game whereas at least with
destiny - there's a lot of PPE as well
so you know yeah so if you want to try
this out if you own overwatch the
patches out live now and so yeah we'll
play some free-for-all here cleanse up
the palate a little bit someone asking
me to play around I don't know if I can
do the Reinhardt meta in FFA and some
people same play mercy we we did this a
little bit earlier but the mercy changes
that we've seen in PTR and the diva
changes aren't live in the game quite
yet
Goku black the road hog update is out
yes so this one includes road hog
Widowmaker Orissa and jump rats changes
so here's the new natto here I'm gonna
play one round for you as mercy okay
because you you feel like there's a
there's a chance that this could be no I
don't think there's no I know there
isn't are you locked into your your hero
that I hope not
pretty bad I don't think you are though
mercy update is not out that's not that
it says he wants you to try the new
mercy to determine if he should get her
golden span but no mercy updates yes so
where they at
is it though Justin oh my god I almost
got that guy I surprised you didn't I
stunned me though so people are asking
which updates as we mentioned Road hogs
is out jump rat I think those are the
two really fake seats that are out right
now and hopefully by the time we get to
see some more of this will have our
overwatch expert Joey back in the office
I love to fly compliment esports tag I'm
just Justin I watch people play
overwatch now he gave up yeah let's kill
him
I held skill done I think I think he
gave up oh why is there a bash in here
that was mercy meta baby the mercy the
mercy clean up kills meta
the mercy update is not in the game but
you would not have guessed it looking at
that last play oh please not me do this
there's a Honda over there
you hate Hanzo more than me oh just got
murdered oh no I was reloading ham six
that means I'm not last
I don't think so mercy is my main
personally no go away hams I'm having a
duel jackass he's doing what you were
doing you've learned if you did he here
we go run it back run it back
who died revive my can I revive myself
oh did he just run from me few times I'm
a mercy main road hog soldier Reaper may
win ste own
how are you playing I don't know who
that is must be want to Joey's friends
oh crap he's got heals yeah yes a bad
heals McCree shoot him so this is the
free-for-all death match team deathmatch
you would stun me and those are in the
arcade mode right now you might have to
download a pretty big update do this
guy's I only have two kills what I feel
like I have more than that this hex
guy's going to town on people though
so what does Mercy's all do and I can't
even use it yeah so free-for-all is not
necessarily the most bound there's a
reason that this is just something in
your arcade mode it's something to have
fun with probably not something where
you want to play his mercy unless I
killed that guy no I didn't how did I do
a hundred damage but not kill him
I want to res myself that's also a
reason why she's not like a self raising
got gold gun McCree didn't show that he
was really good
Oh Chris probably really good for this
mode if you're good with three oh what a
stun he could res once when you die like
warlock yeah yeah just bring yourself
back to life you get like one free rest
and that's tough
this is probably not a mode that I'm
gonna personally blame much of overwatch
is definitely a more team focused game
for me team deathmatch is something I
might play around with are you gonna
spend much time in free-for-all - Eric
no probably not
I probably play some team deathmatch but
that's about it
Tristan Richardson says you should be
like soldier or something yeah soldier's
pretty good did you've been playing so
much soldier I feel like yeah give it a
little late
I don't prep some big changes in this
entire for the mic hit there and I was I
did not even know you was here exactly I
had some really good changes we've
mentioned me as a couple times but jump
I can now hold to concussion mines moves
30% faster when he's using grip tire and
there's no time limit on the 500 GUP
shoe says that pre-parole is good for
boxes since you just need to be in the
top board that's a good point yeah I did
that earlier thing that's a good point
if you do it and if that hex guys still
here
the Slayer yeah I think you get that for
I don't you haven't seen me play well I
think I'll play mercy oh I just got
murked on straps I gotta see it would be
really good for this - do you think
Lucio would be good for this yeah this
man what a good open map Reeves is not
people I regret everything should just
be Farah
Yolo I just all right here let's try so
if you're just joining us we're
obviously streaming in if you're doing
yes then you know that we're streaming
because we're on twitch and YouTube and
on GBA comm if you have any comments
questions or you just want to tell us
how awesome esports day is okay hit us
up in there and we're looking at the
comments as we're going through this Wow
that was nice iron sniper says mine
isn't updating help please console or PC
I don't know he didn't say the solution
is obviously to destroy your console or
PC and just buy a new watch it's
probably that's definitely not good
advice that's not good advice what you
should do is probably just click if
you're in the game go ahead close out
come back in try to do a hard refresh or
if you're on a console you can also
check for updates if it's on PC closing
out of the game to come back and should
bring up the update for that
but it'll be a while how much get pretty
good it sounds like people on console
we're reporting what twelve or sixteen
gig downloads I think we had a six week
light download here on PC but when you
do update them or when you do get that
update look at the tryouts in team
deathmatch and Reaper all right now
we're trying out the free-for-all mode
getting rekt how are you still waiting
it - thanks 300 waddle destiny says who
would you recommend for this obviously
DPS characters I think McCree if you're
good with McCrea tracer seems pretty
good that mercury is really good though
the hex guy Hanzo
Hanzo might be not bad - yeah hey the
healers are gonna be an extra level of
challenge in this yeah it's gonna be
tough for them and most of the support
characters I I think obviously the
people you're gonna see dominating this
are the requisite Reapers sad that like
I did almost better with mercy please
us a sloth leader asks what's your
opinion on Genji not a huge fan he's
really cool aesthetically come on yeah
duck butter oh come on
got like four kills there where is
everyone
y'all outside approach it for us
sometimes you really have a really big
update I'll just bring my personal
console into work and all the things
here mm-hmm if you have work or they're
not closely monitoring that kind of
thing and you can bring in your console
to download something sometimes that
might be a little bit faster although
they're not always friendly about you
doing multigate downloads I guess you
should oh I have my old know I must
hurry
I must make it rain from above Jimmie
ransom says he has 400 hours on
Reinhardt he wonders how he is
it smelled like desperation I know I
said no like desperation team deathmatch
in free-for-all which we're playing
right now in arcade mode those are alive
on all platforms Xbox one ps4 and what
we're playing right now which is PC
getting a lot more respectable now Oh
high noon in the air it's uncle fuzz
which of you watch this play over which
before you know it's not Erik tasty how
dare you Iowa Sully his his account
this is Joey's account one of our other
overwatch streamers Eric Tay is our
eSports champion spider yeah okay he's
not playing on his account right now and
I'm Justin hey Walt keeps calling me an
eSports champion I am NOT Adam Aziz
what's up we're well spread the legend
of tape we're gonna go to leave this
game I'm not even gonna watch the play
the game I can't even get out of it now
if that's me yep geez this guy is solid
aim sometimes you know it's not meant to
be I play some team deathmatch here like
what Matt your tune will probably wrap
up but the update is out so any update
in addition in addition to bringing
free-for-all and team deathmatch also
gives you some changes to road hog junk
rat Arisa and Widowmaker iron sniper the
road hog buff is pretty good
I could try playing road hog here
we tried Widowmaker earlier those buffs
were not enough to save us Road might be
them well I don't play Widow so it's
like a real bad mistake to do that our
go mods if it's downloading it could
just be your internet if it's not going
very fast I did have a point where like
it felt like I was being capped for a
little bit and then it eventually
accelerated so hopefully yours
accelerates stop it that's these are all
people in the office
I think I'm terrible I'm better I call
of duty than I am at overwatch right now
but that's just because I played a lot
during the weekend it's like weird going
back to keep our mouths
The Legend of eSports table never die we
don't have a healer again I guess I
don't really need one who's gonna move
now consoles have access to PTR but this
is not on PTR this is live in the game
right now so whether you're playing on
PC ps4 Xbox one you can also try a team
deathmatch and free-for-all as well as
the updates to the to the characters
that we just mentioned duck Brad
Widowmaker Lisa and right now we're
trying out some road hog as you can see
while regaining health you can also move
to the same time and while you're
regaining help you lose health 50% I
just did
dang it wise is not okay okay how do I
fix it to make it go faster I think the
only fix were a slow connection is
probably rebind is a zoo internet it's
supposed to give you a router going
really slow like slower than normal
you could try reset restart a curve
would and this is the Halloween skin
from last year don't grab him but not
jump road hog right yeah we got healed
yep
but I'm curious to see what kind of cool
skins we get for this Halloween although
I guess that's so far away another over
a month away to see you
my favorite my favorite skin of all time
is still the Halloween mercies I don't
think although the recent summer skin
should be right Elsa says shout me out
shouted how somebody can empower a
teenager kill I I didn't drop enough on
this summer games I didn't quite get all
those gifts that I wanted thought I know
that that's gonna change once Halloween
and winter come around
you fishin the Road hogs take is one of
your mains you feel like the changes
this makes a big difference yeah it does
that being able to e while moving is
pretty insane
Dario ask when does this come out on
console the answer is right now while
the answer is like an hour and a half
ago
yeah now if you're not seeing it you
might want to try to be starting your
console I can see look at that he just
like escaped my alt by healing
there we go Nutcracker definitely
Nutcracker I don't know the thing that's
cool
I didn't gets funny to have to die to a
toy soldier while I'm throwing like nuts
at you oh she got saved there are some
changes to Mercy and diva I think we
tried those out earlier or last week we
haven't tried those out yet but that's
only on PTR right now that's not in the
main game
so some other people are listing out
some of their favorite skins GV Nova
says his second is either never more
like dr. o Nevermore is pretty good yeah
yeah yeah GD Nova says is a good
although you can't be mercy which
totally better redwood gamers is asking
you to play right oh alright I'll get
there
sure
nice overwatch I guess your name is good
movie zooming I'm pretty sure that's
what you mean
worst legendary skin um I think there
were I wasn't really a fan of those uh
that one dlc where we fought off the
robots I can't remember the name of that
one but like there are a lot of
legendary skins that's like didn't feel
like legendary skins and it was like man
how are those like considered legendary
skins yeah like not that they were ugly
they were just they felt too expensive
for being legendary status mm-hmm okay
that's a good point
all right we're gonna go do one more
I'll play a little Reinhart at the start
and someone I'm yeah if you have any
other characters that you'd like to see
teh Domini to match a dry up rising
rising alright they're fine like I think
those were fun I just thought they look
more like legendary skins they didn't
have a lot of as much touch as I would
want out of a legendary skin
I suppose the the Halloween skin for
Reaper is also called the Sleepy Hollow
along with the top gear though those
holiday ones like Halloween in
particular and holiday winter coming up
mm-hmm the Christmas skins were torn as
Santa like totally awesome here we go
let's go see all right we'll try a
little bit right hard but sorry it does
not have the best skeptic
dude I'm all about the anime reinhardt
though I bet so when that came out when
I can Walt came out I bought that
Reinhardt's can right away now right
hearts awesome
Nikki makes me think the most of we have
no heal or Justin see that's good if
somebody like me come in I don't might
be a healer gotta go find health
I need healing so right now we're trying
out the team deathmatch room I am free
for all earlier magazines in this latest
patch and it is live on PC ps4 PC and
Xbox one where it's not quite as family
it is Arcade Mode it's not as balanced I
think as some of the other modes but
it's not meant to be this is meant to be
kind of a fun way to play the game home
people have asked for for a bit Tracy
sorry yeah that nut cracker skin
gotcha and we're not on PTR right now
this is live in the game so if you're at
home or if you have access to your
homeless daughter you can try this out
yourself I almost out snipe the widow
take a good Ginji tonight
definitely not again d you are crazy sir
so if you like this stream here on
gamespot we play quite a bit of
overwatch we'll be playing a lot of
shooters in the upcoming holiday today
is probably our go to destiny expert
normally we have Joey here on the stream
with us who if you've watched any of our
destiny screens or overwatch streams
earlier you've definitely seen him Ami's
Webber splatoon experts so we do a lot
of trees over here on GameSpot whoa
that's got to kill him all right he yeah
you got a triple off that so as we have
more overwatch updates coming we'll be
keeping an eye out I'm sure junker town
will be coming sometime pretty soon at
least in the next couple weeks which was
what we saw at Gamescom which is the new
new map we'll probably get a chance to
try that out at some point as well as
some things that are only on PTR right
now which is yes mercy and diva who had
some really big buffs to their
characters
and in the next couple of weeks we'll be
playing a lot of shooters in addition to
overwatch as those updates come out
probably some destiny to call duty the
only one take place is destiny though
whoa
who's your worst character tank Widow oh
dang it oh you know we also have Melissa
on coming up that is true that is in
like November so just a few more months
we'll have a bliss pod I was incredibly
surprised when we got doom fist lolicon
and so Blizzcon is still blizzards
biggest event and that's when you expect
to have the biggest announcements this
felt like such a big thing and it's been
something we've been anticipating for
such a long time do you think they're
gonna top that this year at Blizzcon oh
that's tough or hand a bit like oh and
they just did two character animations
essentially which I find insane really
big updates that would have fit
perfectly Blizzcon yeah
they got if they're that confident like
I feel like they got to have something
right like there's no way they would but
do you think do you think it's a
character do you think it's a new map
you think it's both or do you think it's
gotta be character right feel like I
feel like it I feel like it has to be a
character because that's what that's
what gets that high that's what makes
you really excited oh that's new that's
a nice game
well he's got gold bow these guys not
messing around
Oh oh hello
oh and he's soft salt Oh feels good all
right Justin I think that's kinda you
want to bring up our little software
there yeah so thanks so much for joining
us here on our overwatch screen stream
we were playing some free-for-all and
death match which are live now on ps4
and across the consoles so if if you're
looking to try this out yourself and you
have overwatch of course you can try
that personally it's a really big update
though so pretty prepared for you know
well I think around 12 to 16 gigs of
downloading yeah and don't forget
tomorrow guys we have the log ok
legendary skin did he have that one no
he didn't
sick yeah well thank you to the can Cara
kya for telling us open-loop walk so we
got loot box there for Joey their
legendary skin that's awesome
feels good but yeah tomorrow is going to
be the lobby Thursday I believe I'm
gonna do Ark survival evolved with Rob
do some Dino hunting and I think Friday
we're gonna do some more Cod Cod's gonna
be back again for beta so tune in to
that obviously and thank you guys for
watching so much thanks Justin thanks
guys outro yep